bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors encore une fois
discussions prolongées
ça montre qu'il ya une volonté des deux
côtés ne parvenir à un accord oui je
pense que c'est la conclusion qui
s'impose si vous aviez regardé les
journaux ce matin
vous auriez cru que de nous il était à
peu près certain c'est ce que boris
johnson avait dit d'ailleurs il avait
dit que c'était très très probable qu'il
dira qu'il y aurait anodine alors voilà
que tout change que depuis que depuis
midi en fait la dernière échéance la
énième échéance est de nouveau repoussée
donc oui nous pouvons conclure qu'il y à
un accord enfin la volonté d'avoir un
accord ce qui me préoccupe a su ça
c'était à ce moment où maintenant c'est
que et bien ça me semblait une drôle de
façon de gouverner un pays est de
gouverner une union européenne arracher
un accord de dernière minute ou après la
dernière minute cela malheureusement
même si un accord est conclu
cela ne va pas enlever la très grande
incertitude qui pèse déjà nous sommes à
quelques semaines de la sortie
définitive qui pèse déjà n'est ce pas
sur les entreprises et sur les haies sur
les citoyens qui ne savent pas où ils
seront dans deux ou trois semaines donc
je pense que c'est une mauvaise manière
de 2 da rold d'organiser les choses
c'est plutôt une façon de ne pas les
organiser
mais voilà il semble que les deux partis
les deux côtés ont décidé de ne pas
faire un sou dans l'abyme dans l'abyme
qui serait le no deal vous le disions
c'est vrai qu'on entend ici là le
pessimisme
d'un coup dur c'est la bonne taille
haine de l'autre de boris johnson s'est
un peu floues mais selon vous est ce
qu'il est une tendance qui se dégage
écoutez tout d'abord je pense que nous
sommes face à une vraie incertitude
c'est ce que un ancien ministre
américain de la défense appelée les les
inconnus connu je pense que ce basque
que c'est ce que cela peut basculer dans
un sens ou dans l'autre donc il est
inutile de me demander ce que je pense
puisque je pense qu'il ya une vraie
incertitude dans la réalité mais la
conclusion que je tiers du fait que
madame fanta la haine et ont dit voici
un jour ou deux qu'elle allait prendre
une décision aujourd'hui dimanche est là
et ne l'a elle l'a pas fait on n'a pas
pris une décision elle aurait elle
aurait pu dire à me dit que nous avions
dit qu'elle avait dit qu'elle prendrait
une décision dimanche et que la décision
était prise par exemple de passer à un
odile elle n'a pas dit elle dit le
contraire a dit que nous continuons à
négocier
donc je pense que la seule conclusion
qui s'impose c'est que les deux les deux
parties pensent
malgré tout qu'ils pourront peut-être
combler les divergences qui reste et qui
sont importantes alors on vient
d'apprendre en boris johnson qui dit
selon lui qu' il n'y a probablement pas
d'accord en vue
on croit ou pas si lui le dit qu'il n'y
aura pas d'accord et qu'on se dirige
vers anodine oui mais je vous dis c'est
ce qu'il a dit hier ou avant-hier comme
le tout comme adam 22 la haine a dit
hier ou avant-hier qu'elle prendrait une
décision aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la
vraie incertitude les les deux parties
essayent de trouver un accord mais il
n'y arrive pas peut-être qu'ils n'y
arriveront jamais mais nous qui sommes à
l'extérieur de tout cela nous ne pouvons
pas savoir ce qui se vend ce qui va se
passer les deux les deux sont toujours
possible deal ou no deal simplement je
répète je tire la conclusion que nous
n'avons pas eu aujourd'hui à nos deals
annonce dans l'aude il
cela ouvre bien évidemment la
possibilité d'un deal arraché à la
dernière minute
alors andy la race et à la dans les
mines ou peut-être des négociations qui
vont se poursuivre au-delà du 30
en décembre est-ce que ça c'est un
scénario envisageable je ne crois pas
non parce que cela reviendrait à d'abord
cela serait contraire à la loi au
royaume uni vos téléspectateurs se
souviennent peut-être de l'agonie du
gouvernement theresa may et puis de là
une situation très difficile dont a
hérité choristes yong billets 2019 c'est
quand il a remporté les élections fin
2010 9 débuts à 2020 il a fait voter une
loi qui rend impossible tout tout
nouveau report de la période transitoire
donc la période transitoire elven
arrivait à son terme le 31 décembre donc
est-ce que ils pourront continuer à
négocier peut-être certains domaines
spécifiques au delà de cette date
peut-être mais non le 31 décembre c'est
vraiment le moment où avant lequel il
aura fallu prendre une décision toujours
les mêmes points d'achoppement la pêche
la gouvernance oui les trois la pêche
les règles sur la concurrence que
bruxelles voudrait imposer au royaume
uni pour empêcher à ce que le royaume
uni divergent trop des normes
européennes
et puis la frontière et en irlande
la question de savoir quels seront les
les possibilités pour éviter une
frontière du rhône et au monde ce sont
les trois grands domaines de discussions
mais ceci dit la question de l'irlande
et les secondaires si je puis dire
à la question de l'ensemble c'est à dire
que si les deux côtés les deux parties
arrivent à conclure un accord
raisonnable comme le royaume uni le
souhaitent avec un commerce qui va
continuer un peu comme avant bien
évidemment à ce moment là la question de
la frontière en irlande n'est plus
d'actualité puisque si le commerce est
libre eh bien il n'y aura pas de
frontières dur mais voilà ce sont les
trois thèmes qui restent qui restent
ouvert et je crois que le problème c'est
que bruxelles est un projet idéologique
l'union européenne est un projet
idéologique alors que les britanniques
ont toujours eu mais ça à vos
téléspectateurs de save a toujours eu
les britanniques ont toujours eu une
approche pragmatique c'est à dire que
pour eux c'était une question
commerciale et pragmatique
mais l'union européenne c'est un pop up
dans l'esprit de ceux qui sont pour
l'union européenne à bruxelles
c'est un projet idéologique il s'agit de
créer un état fédéral ou de avancer vers
une étape supérieure de la civilisation
humaine
donc en fait ce qui s'affrontent ici
dans ces négociations ce sont deux
visions fondamentalement
irréconciliables qui résume cette
différence elle résume en fait toute la
difficulté qu'a éprouvé le royaume uni
au sein de l'union européenne depuis 40
ans john laughland merci d'avoir été
avec moi on dirait que sur un ton franc
je rappelle que vous êtes doctorat en
philosophie spécialiste de la
géopolitique